alright Beatrice is with us in San
Antonio Texas how are you Beatrice I'm
doing well and thank you so much for
saving my marriage Dave ever since we
start your financial piece me and my
husband never argue about money so it's
been a blessing thank you
very cool how long y'all been married
we've been married for 11 years but
we've been together way longer than that
so it's been really really nice to not
kill each other after 11 years right now
we have one dispute and I was like we've
just got to call the Dave Ramsey show
that way we could just put it into it
figure out what we're going to do okay I
have a question for you long so we're on
baby step we've got back into debt and
we're in baby step number two again
unfortunately and I have about 20
different envelopes that I've
established and ever since New Year's
came around with resolutions my husband
was like let's go ahead and just stop
the envelopes and just concentrate on
the necessities like grocery money gas
money and mortgage those kind of things
and just kill the rest of the envelopes
and put all of the savings toward our
debt and so we're out and I'm saying we
continue the envelopes that way there's
no surprises when we need tires or when
you need an oil change or what-have-you
so I'm trying to figure out what do we
do okay probably a combination of the
two 20 sounds pretty wide and saw but I
like his intensity about cutting back
and throwing everything at the debt
but you're making a solid case for
there's you need to be ready for tires
okay so I would not cut out for instance
your car repair envelope
I wouldn't over fund that I wouldn't
want $10,000 in there but you're gonna
have car repairs and if it carries month
to month a little bit in it that's okay
that's not a bad thing
so if you're talking about oil change or
car tires that's a car repair envelope
right mm-hmm
so you know I don't know how you got to
20 though what is it what all these
things you're saving for okay so like
contacts and glasses for me and the kids
home funds when we need pest control
prescriptions doctor bills kids funds
whenever there's like
you know photos or they need new shoes
or what have you tires Christmas savings
oil changes and maintenance licenses all
changes then you have four tires yes
mm-hmm okay you've got this split tooth
in you're gonna drive yourself crazy
that's why do your kids shoes have their
own envelope kids like kids phones will
change car call clothing kids fun for
like whenever they need like the school
pictures or if they need miscellaneous
kids stuff like the school pictures or
field trips or whatever that's a
reasonable thing that's not something
you cut out but you probably need to
combine some of these envelopes and put
the shoes and the clothing envelope and
let's start having a you know a
breakdown for that at this stage of the
game I'm probably not having a Christmas
envelope today but I probably would
start one somewhere down about August or
September to get ready for Christmas
because in the mean time I want you to
turn into this dad okay okay so you've
done a really good thing because you've
gotten very intentional the two of you
are talking about money you're
communicating and not killing each other
this is a good thing so all of these
things are proper you're doing
everything right and the normal process
is as you get better and better about
budgeting and using the envelopes you
use less and less and less of them
thirty years later we have three Wow
that's all we have three envelopes
everything else we do with the budget
and the debit card okay but sharon has a
clothing envelope we have a food
envelope and I can't even think with the
other one entertainment I think is the
other one but you know a lot of
everything else we do we just use the
debit card because we've gotten in the
rhythm of the budget for thirty years
okay so it's gotten smaller and smaller
smaller but there are still things you
see Sharon at the grocery store she
still pulls out that Rachel Cruze
designer envelope first thingy that
Rachel sells and it Sharon like the new
one so she's got that and that's what
you'll see come out and you'll see her
paying for cash for her groceries but if
I take Sharon out on a date night at a
nice restaurant it's probably going to
be a debit card nowadays
but at the start we had at the start we
had a different restaurant envelope than
a food envelope so the way you're
starting is the right way to start but
just to tell you that over time as you
get better at this you're gonna use
fewer and fewer and fewer and today I
would go ahead and combine a few of
these you're talking about and probably
think about one or two that you can
empty and catch up later to get on this
debt like your husband is suggesting you
guys are gonna win I can tell this is
the Dave Ramsey show